hier à nouveau numéro d'enquêté
exclusive mais moi ce que je retiens
d'enquêté que philippe c'est ce qu'a dit
bernard de la villardière il a accordé
une interview au monde ce week end et
bernard la villardière a déclaré qu'il
avait fait condamner un chroniqueur de
l'équipe
ce chroniqueur c'est gilles verdez vous
avez été paraît que vous avez été sept
fait condamner voilà je vous donne un
scoop je viens de faire condamner gilles
verdez pour diffamation il m'a traiter
d'islamophobe chez hanouna à chaque fois
qu'il peut se payer enquête exclusive il
m'accuse de ne pas faire mon travail de
journaliste
voilà donc et c'est vrai que alors il
paraît que vous avez été condamné
gibert death valley nous en parler dans
un instant parce qu'on aimerait en
savoir plus sur cette sombre affaire
allez vous
porter un bracelet électronique ou pas
on a besoin de le savoir est assez vite
vous allez nous dire ce qui s'est passé
et à quoi vous avez été mon année merci
pendant que bernard derme avaient
attaqué à propos de l'ensemble des
déclarations des critiques positives ou
négatives surtout négatives que j'ai
fait ici sur son émission enquête
exclusive
ouais d'accord la particularité c'est
qu'il n'a attaqué que moi dans ces cas
là il a tout à fait le droit mais
traditionnellement on peut attaquer les
missions à percy fernard docteur donc
vous qui l'avez diffuseur il a happé que
moi c'est très épais et il a gagné sur
islamophobie donc j'ai été condamné pour
diffamation qu'il a perdu sur tout le
reste ce qui fait qu'on peut continuer à
tout le reste alors toutes les critiques
sur l'émission
parce que son but c'était de dire il ya
un acharnement ses critiques sur
l'émission ça crée un acharnement contre
moi mais c'est ce que disent tout et
c'est elle qui avait dit aussi tf1 et
demi qu'on s'acharne et absolument les
squats ont dit du bien de koh lanta ou
deux oublis et donc il a été retoqué là
dessus on peut continuer à dire ce qu'on
pense de son émission voilà c'est juste
islamophobie ce que je voudrais dire
aussi c'est que comme il a attaqué que
moi j'ai été le seul à être condamné et
qu'on garde et n'avait donc y avait en
tout ou à peu près avec les frais de
justice était autour de 5000 euros à lui
quand même donc je m'apprêtais à faire
un chèque camp et se tient à vous rendre
hommage il faut que les téléspectateurs
le sache quand vous et lionel stan qui
directeur général dale toyne h2o m'ont
dit ben on s'est tu as été condamné en
pondant propre mais c'était pendant
l'émission donc tu ne payent rien c'est
nous qui payons et vous aviez mis
également un très bon avocat à ma
disposition avec lequel on a très bien
bossé donc je voulais vous remercier
parce que
et chroniqueurs seront pas payés pendant
un mois mais c'est normal c'est normal
et personnel